DeSantis is the future of free America
and Trump has to figure out if he wants
to fit in that or not yes does Trump
have the power to burn the whole thing
down right now and Destroy DeSantis
probably could he figure out a way to do
it and just split the party and just
create endless chaos yeah I voted for
Trump the second time I've met him I've
liked him I I've interviewed him he's
got to figure this thing out now in a
decent way uh and I don't know if he has
it in him but you can feel it people are
people are starting to turn now you
don't think he has it in him to realize
that it's the Santa so you don't think
he has it in him to make another run you
don't think he has nothing in them to
the form be a unifier for the Republican
Party does he have it in him to be he
could be the king maker imagine if
instead of next week instead of what
everyone thinks is going to happen which
is that he announces that he's running
imagine if he gets up there and he says
you know I've looked at the lay of the
land I've been doing this for a long
time I'm of a certain age DeSantis he's
the guy he's the guy and let me help
what a great and not not even an ending
but what a beautiful next chapter of the
Trump story I'll get out there I'll do
rallies I'll fight for the it's all
you're I can already see it
yeah but I mean that's a great that's a
hopeful wishful thinking but as a New
Yorker as somebody with his ego I wish I
wish I agree
but I love it maybe we gotta maybe we
gotta pump the hell out of that story so
he hears it because if Trump is one
thing he does hear what people want you
know and if the story is man you can
still be loved you can be loved and
accomplish some of the things that you
wanted to accomplish but getting through
the machine again and that you're gonna
have to take out this I mean that the
sanctimonious line a couple days ago
yeah why who's sanctimonious did you
look up the definition of sanctimonious
I looked it up yeah and it's basically
like
okay and again I like Trump this is not
show the definition of what's saying
yeah it's kind of by the way because
when he comes up with crooked Hillary or
you know whacking crazy Nancy sleepy Joe
sleep it's not off the cuff yeah I mean
a lot of the stuff that he does is
certainly off the cup don't no doubt but
this is well thought out all right we're
going to Sleepy Joe sanctimonious making
a show of being morally Superior to
other people so he's like I could say
anything I want about Ron the scam to
whatever name you want to go he's like I
want to call him you're not holier than
thou okay you're not chosen by God buddy
he picked that on purpose
so in my in my opinion give me one
example one example ever in Trump's life
where he's like I will take a back seat
you be the leader never I've never seen
it no I know but that's why the story
right like if he wants to do the hero's
journey here it's like man do it no I
know I know it's crazy I know it's crazy
but it's worth getting more people to
talk about it for the next two weeks
because otherwise he's going to announce
and they are gonna have to battle it out
I would say this DeSantis will be by far
if if he wants to run I don't know if he
wants to run I know him decently well
now I was I was you were at the library
I Victory I did the my show from the
victory thing I mean the guy sick he's
surrounded by incredible people he's
competent he's decent he's clearly a
good husband he's a good father it's
like it's not going to get better than
this I don't worship politicians I don't
no it is not going to get better than
this guy and I would say the real
question for those of us that live in uh
in Florida and I really honestly can't
believe that you live in California
um is do we want him to run you know I
think there's an argument it to just
keep him here and let's keep this place
as strong as it can be and
you know I think I think that's worth
thinking about the opening the opening
where you have an opening to capitalize
he's
yeah he's never been better no I mean
okay so okay so 62 out of 67. what's he
gonna do better four years from now like
what's gonna be better than today you
know everybody won in your state you
flip the purple into red
are you gonna be able to Peak that if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell